خلال السفر انت بحاجه الى التواصل مع اهلك
اصدقائك او زملائك بالعمل
بغض النظر عن مدى حرصك الا ان استخدام
الانترنت عبر الهاتف في الخارج قد يكلفك
رسوما باهظه التكاليف طبعا
معظم المسافرين يصدمون
بفاتوره كبار مما كانوا يتوقعون وقد يقضون
عطلتهم في قلق بشان فاتوره الهاتف عند
العوده
سنتعرف على الخطوات التي يمكنك اتخاذها
للتاكد من انك لن تعود لتجد فاتوره هاتف
ضخمه بانتظارك مع الحفاظ على مستوى
الاتصال الذي تحتاجه اثناء تواجدك في
الخارج
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو هاشم شميساني خبير
مشاريع التحول الرقمي اهلا بك يا هاشم
معنا صباح النور صباح الخير حياك الله طيب
احنا الان في موسم الصيف الاجازات على
الابواب العطل الصيفيه شو نعمل احسن هل
فعلا ناخذ باقه او هناك هيك تفاصيل صغيره
فيما يتعلق بالباقات اللي احنا اصلا
ماخدينها في بلدنا لازم نكون منتبهين لها
عشان نستفيد من باقات التجوال العالميه
ولا ناخذ سنكورد من الدوله اللي احنا
رايحين عليها تلفونك صامت
يعطينا تدريب شكرا على الاستضافه
يعني خيار جدا مهم ولازم اختياره بذكاء
قبل السفر اول شيء لازم نحدد نوع السفر شو
نوع السفر اللي احنا رايحين نعمله اذا كان
السفر لعمل في خيارات اخرى
اذا كان السفر للاستجمام والاستمتاع هذا
في خيار المختلف عن مثلا خلينا نبدا بنوع
السفر لكان نوع السفر مثلا للعمل تركيز
بده يكون اكثر على الدقائق الاتصال بيكون
على الاس ام اس بيكون على الخدمه هاي
الاشياء اذا كان اكثر بالضبط بالضبط اذا
كان صفر مثلا
للاستمتاع والاستجمام وهيك لا بدي اركز
على اكثر اجوده الانترنت اكثر فهون مده
السفر يعني اذا كانت مده السفر عم نحكي عن
انتقال بين بلاد مختلفه بفترات قصيره ثلاث
ايام اربع ايام الخيار بدنا نختاره بيختلف
طبعا هلا رح نحكي الفروقات حتى حتى ناخذها
بطريقه عمليه ساسافر مع عائلتي لمده خلينا
نقول شهر
خلينا نقول شهر بس بس
لانه اشواق وانت ما يصير شهر راح نتنقل في
ثلاث بلدان مثلا كل بلد عشره ايام
فبالتالي انا احتاج انترنت اولادي يحتاجون
انترنت كيف من الممكن ان اوفر ماديا على
نفسي اول شيء مثلا هذا مثال جميل بهذه
الحاله ابدا بهذه الحاله ابدا ما بنختار
باقات التجوال من البلد المقيم فيه انا
جئت منه ما اختارها بتكون التكلفه فلكيه
فلكيه نختار دائما اللي عند الوصول السم
عند الوصول بهذه الحاله اللي تتكلم عنها
ولانه هذه الخيار كمان بيعطينا القدره اني
استخدم هوت سبوت او هوت سبوت انه جهاز احط
فيها السيم كارد يوزع للعائله شيء ثاني في
عندك عائله توزع لها اكثر من جهه هذه
وجهتي اجيب شريحه منه
الانترنت من هذا البلد نحكي بالخيارات طيب
في عنا ثلاث خيارات دائما لما ناخذ
طريقه الشبكه عندنا الطريقه الاولى اللي
تكلمنا عنها البلد المضيف اللي انا رايح
عليه بشتري منه البطاقه والحزمه كامله قبل
ما تكمل بس اشتري البطاقه من المطار ولا
من السوق احسن
ما يقارن بكلفه انه اروح تجوال اللي هلا
راح نذكر الطرق اول شيء ونحكي الفروقات
بينهم الطريقه الاولى اللي هي نشغل باقه
تجوال الكل بيعرفها والطريقه الثانيه اني
اشتري بالبلد اللي انا بنزل فيه مباشره
سيم كارد واشيل السيم كارد مالي واحط
السيم كارد جديد والطريقه الثالثه كثير
ناس ما بيعرفوها اللي هي استخدم خدمات
الانترنت الدولي اللي هي مش انترنت
هلا كل طريقه الها فوائدها هو الها مساوا
خلينا نتكلم عن التطبيقات بما انه مش
الكثير يعرفوها تطبيقات كثيره موجوده
تعطيك حزمه باقه انترنت لكن السعر شلون
السعر جوده الانترنت خلينا نتكلم عن يعني
محسنها انها تعطيك خدمات مرنه تعطيك تغطي
اقليم ما تغطي بلد يعني ممكن اروح مثلا
شفره اوروبا تقول لك اغطي لك اوروبا ما
تقول لك اغطي لك كل بلد واسحاسبك على كل
بلد اغطي لك المنطقه كلها كمان اني بقدر
اغير بنفس اللحظه بقدر اغير مباشره على
التطبيق هلا شو مشكلتها من مشاكلها
الشركات هذه غير موثوق وغير معروفه بشكل
عام يعني ما في شركه هلا مطاغه على السوق
ماخذه كل الماركت الماركت ما في هذا الشيء
هاي مشكله تبعهم قليل جدا بكون الشيء
الثاني الجوده تبع الانترنت ما بتكون
عاليه جدا زي لما اخذ من السم المحلي لانه
بالاخر هاي الشركات بتستخدم الشبكات
المحليه في وسيط بيني وبين الشركه المحليه
فما بتكون وكمان سعرها متوسط لا يكون كثير
عالي ولا يكون منخفض
قبل ما انهي بس حابه اسالك انت ذكرت بانه
من الافضل اذا كنت رايحه لفتره طويله اني
اخذ سم او شريحه من البلد الوجهه من وجهتي
طيب واقيم السم اقيم شريحتي انا الاصليه
الشريحه ممكن الشريحه
عندي تواصل عن طريق الواتساب مع رقمي
الاصلي
بالرقم
حتى بعض الشركات لما اروح انا عده شركات
في هذا البلد ما اعرف من الجيد بدك تدور
قبل ما تروح ولكن نحكي نقطه رئيسيه مهمه
قبل ما ننهي اللي هي مثال نعطي مثال على
الفرق بين التجوال سريع جدا على التجوال
باقه العشره جيجا تبع الانترنت المعروف
بكل العالم لو بدي اطلع هو من الامارات
واشغل رومين قال عشره جيجا تكلفني 200
درهم لو بروح اي بلد نحكي بلاد وجهات
سياحيه حاليا تركيه مصر مصر مثلا عم نحكي
عن السعر عند الوصول 10 جيجا عم نحكي عن
200 جنيه يعني عم نحكي عن 25 درهم شوفوا
ثمان اضعاف تركيا نفس الشيء 20 ضعف هاشم
الشميساني يا الخبير في مشاريع التحول
الرقمي شكرا جزيلا لك تشرفني يعطيكم
العافيه شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات